Cris de mouettes
...
Cris indistincts d'enfants
Propos indistincts d'enfants
...
Cris des mouettes
Propos indistincts d'enfants
...
Vrombissements de motos
Propos indistincts d'enfants
...
-T'as 14 ans.
-Ouais, je sais.
-Tu prévois déjà ça ?
-Bah, ouais.
On se lance dans les projets.
-Imagine, dans un mois,
t'es plus avec...
Tu vas pas te lancer
dans des projets...
T'as 14 ans, tu parles déjà
d'avoir des gosses.
-Bah ouais.
-A 14 ans, t'as pas la maturité
d'avoir des gosses.
Même si t'es mature,
genre, tu vois...
Je sais pas...
A 14 ans, t'as pas la maturité
d'avoir des enfants.
-Bah, après peut-être que...
-C'est comme si t'as 14 ans
et tu te dis : "J'aurai une maison",
tout de suite
et tout...
-Ouais...
-C'est pas maintenant !
-C'est pour faire des projets.
-C'est pas maintenant,
imagine dans un mois,
t'es plus avec.
-Ca, on n'en sait rien.
C'est le destin aussi.
-Le destin ?
-Bah oui.
-Si tu veux.
-Bah, imagine ton gars,
il habite à Marseille, imagine.
Tu vas pas le voir.
-J'irai pas voir
un gars à Marseille.
-Non, mais c'est une question.
Imagine, tu pars en vacances.
Tu le rencontres,
tu tombes amoureuse.
Tu restes,
jusque-là, c'est bon.
-Bah je sortirai pas avec.
-Bah oui, mais après tu peux tomber
amoureuse, etc., puis boum.
-Bah non.
-Bah si.
-Mais j'irai pas choisir
un gars à Marseille !
Je suis pas conne,
non plus.
-Mais imagine !
On dit pas conne, déjà.
On dit pas conne, merci.
-Si.
-Non, on dit "bête", déjà, merci.
Comment je t'ai reprise...
Bref, du coup...
Imagine...
-Bah non, déjà, je choisirai pas
un gars de Marseille,
ou de plus loin, genre.
-Dans tous les cas,
je vais déménager.
Là, c'est pas le bout du monde
non plus, c'est Boulogne.
-C'est à 30 minutes peut-être,
mais c'est chiant.
-Il y a le train.
-C'est la même chose.
-Imagine la semaine prochaine,
t'es plus avec.
-Imagine, juste.
C'est pas vrai, tu imagines juste.
-Bah ouais, bah je sais pas...
Tu aurais fait des projets
pour rien...
-Mais ça,
tu sais pas,
c'est dans ton instinct,
dans ta tête...
-Comment tu le sais ?
-Tu le deviens.
Tu le choisis pas, tu le deviens.
-Ca, je sais, mais...
Comment tu le sais, genre...
Comment ça fait "paf"
dans ta tête ?
-Mais nan, ça a pas fait "paf"
dans ma tête, non,
c'est juste que...
-Oui, mais imagine, genre,
après, ça se réalisera pas.
-T'en sais rien.
-Genre Satam, il aura pas de boulot,
un truc comme ça.
-T'en sais rien, au contraire,
il va essayer de réussir sa vie.
Il va continuer ses études,
il va travailler. Moi-même,
je vais travailler,
ça va être un bon père.
-Tu sais pas. Imagine, il trouve pas
de boulot, ou un truc comme ça.
-Il va quand même trouver
quelque chose.
Il va pas rester au chômage.
-Pas forcément.
-C'est pas le genre de gars
à rester au chômage.
Il veut travailler et avoir une vie.
-Heureusement.
-Tu peux pas dire
que c'est un bâtard.
Tu l'as vu une fois,
tu le traites de bâtard.
-C'est la première impression,
je l'aime pas.
Je l'ai vu, je me suis dit :
"Je l'aime pas."
-Tu peux pas dire ça. Tu juges,
alors que tu le connais même pas.
Ca se fait pas envers la personne.
Imagine, toi, on te voit
et d'un coup, on te juge.
Ca te plaira pas. Je pense
que ça lui plaira pas non plus.
-Ouais, mais mettons, j'ai un gars
et genre... genre tu l'aimes pas.
Tu vas pas dire :
"Je l'aime bien."
Tu dis ce que tu penses.
-Faut apprendre à le connaître.
-Mais tu vas dire
ce que tu penses.
-Non, il faut que t'apprennes
à le connaître, tu juges trop vite.
Quand tu vas avoir un copain
ou une copine, ça va être pareil.
-Je suis là quand même.
-Oui, mais non, mais tu...
-Pour moi, j'ai l'impression
j'suis plus là, genre.
-Quand tu grandis,
t'as besoin d'être avec ton copain.
-Mais tes potes existent
quand même.
-Mais oui, mais après,
on oublie quand même un peu.
D'un côté,
c'est bien aussi, les amis,
mais d'un côté,
t'as besoin d'être avec ton copain,
sinon ça va pas aller
dans ta relation.
-Je continue à dire qu'à 15 ans,
t'as pas la maturité pour avoir
des enfants.
-Regarde, Sarah, elle y arrive bien.
Elle travaille peut-être pas,
son copain non plus,
mais au final, regarde,
ses enfants sont super bien,
ils sont... enfin, ils sont
pas non plus dans les rues.
Elle a de l'autorité,
c'est une bonne mère.
-Je trouve qu'elle s'occupe
pas vraiment de ses enfants.
Ils sont quand même assez jeunes
et ils sont dehors.
-Ils sont pas toujours dehors.
Elle a de l'autorité
sur ses enfants.
-J'sais pas, moi, à 3 ans,
j'allais pas dehors.
-Faut pas abuser,
elle a pas 3 ans, sa petite !
-Mais nan, mais je sais pas,
quand t'es petit...
-C'est une mère bien,
elle s'en sort dans la vie.
Elle a pas la vie foutue.
Franchement, elle est bien.
Elle est heureuse.
Propos indistincts d'enfants
...
-Y a 3-3.
Cris des mouettes
Quelqu'un en vélo s'approche.
...
-Eh, Kyliana.
Pourquoi tu fais la gueule, là ?
-Qu'est-ce que ça peut te faire ?
-Souris un peu, là, non ?
-Bah non.
-Vas-y, souris un peu, là !
-Non.
Je fais ce que je veux,
en fait.
-Vas-y, arrête
de faire ta gueule, là !
Vas-y, là, réponds !
Il siffle.
Oh oh !
-Vas-y, dégage.
J'ai pas envie de te parler, bouge.
-Vas-y, tu saoules, là.
Tu m'as saoulé.
Il s'éloigne avec son vélo.
...
-A tout à l'heure,
je vais à l'école.
Allez, viens.
A tout à l'heure.
Cris d'enfants
...
Je vais chercher ta petite soeur
à l'école.
Bonjour, madame.
Elle a été sage ?
Non ? Bah alors,
t'étais pas sage à l'école !
On va à la maison,
maintenant.
-Bah non, moi, ça ne va pas trop
en ce moment.
Je me sens triste,
j'sais pas où j'en suis,
je suis perdue.
La dernière fois, je suis rentrée,
j'ai été dans ma chambre
et je me suis mise à pleurer,
je savais même pas pourquoi.
J'crois que j'ai l'impression
de pas être libre, genre enfermée,
comme si ma vie était déjà tracée.
J'ai l'impression
que je suis pas une gamine,
mais pas une adulte non plus.
Quand j'étais petite,
je me posais pas
toutes ces questions,
c'était plus simple.
Maintenant,
y en a qui sont en couple,
elles ont leur vie de famille,
elles ont des enfants...
Voilà, mais moi, non.
En tout cas, moi,
je m'occupe pas des mecs.
Si y en a pas,
y en a pas.
Genre, je sais pas
comment l'expliquer.
Bah moi,
j'ai jamais été amoureuse.
Ca s'est fait comme ça,
d'un seul coup, en 5e-4e, quoi.
J'avais 12-13 ans.
En gros, j'étais méchante,
entre guillemets.
J'avais de la haine contre les gens,
je sais pas pourquoi.
De la haine même contre les gens
qui m'avaient rien fait.
J'étais plus en train de traîner
avec des garçons qu'avec des filles.
Si je passais dans la rue,
que quelqu'un me regardait mal,
je disais :
"C'est quoi, ton problème ?
Tu me fais pas peur."
J'foutais le bordel, enfin...
Je traitais tout le monde.
Même les profs, je les insultais.
*Musique rap
*...
Un camion passe.
...
*...
Cris des mouettes
...
*...
-Caleb !
Cri d'enfant lointain
-Mais non !
...
Gémissements et cris
-Vous faites quoi ?
Cassez-vous !
Dégagez.
Tu veux que je dégage ?
Mais non, dégage, fils de pute !
Ta mère.
Propos indistincts
-Allez, cassez-vous, là.
-Ouais.
-Sale pute !
Il crache.
-T'es un crasseux, hein.
-Ton cousin,
il est en prison pour meurtre !
-Ferme ta gueule, casse-toi aussi.
Casse-toi, allez.
-Allez !
Va manger du pain !
-Dégage !
-Ta gueule, toi !
-Casse-toi.
Toi, ta gueule, espèce de PD.
Vas-y, bouge. Bon, allez, casse-toi.
Elle crache.
Nardinamouk.
Ta gueule, PD.
OK !
Pourquoi vous êtes venus ?
Cassez-vous, non ?
-Ta gueule !
Propos indistincts
...
-Tu crois me faire peur, en plus ?
Pouilleux, eh !
...
Ta gueule, pouilleux, dégage !
-Ta gueule.
-Toi, ta gueule.
Quand je suis arrivée au lycée,
je me suis dit :
"Faut que je me comporte bien.
"J'ai grandi,
faut que je devienne mature."
Avant, je me prenais pour un mec.
J'étais toujours en survêt et tout.
Je mettais des TN...
Enfin...
J'étais un garçon manqué.
Quand j'ai vu que, ben,
toutes les filles,
elles s'habillaient bien, 'fin...
Elles étaient...
Je sais pas comment expliquer,
mais... féminines.
Y avait que moi
qui étais en survêt, quoi.
Je me suis dit : "Je vais essayer
de redevenir comme ça."
Et après, ben, j'ai réussi
à me rhabiller comme une fille,
j'ai commencé à remettre mes jeans,
mes crop tops,
pour être acceptée,
pour que les gens arrêtent de parler
et qu'ils arrêtent de m'insulter.
-Comment tu vas compter
t'y prendre ?
-Pour la séduire ?
-Pour la draguer ?
-Séduire.
-Pour la séduire ? Euh...
-Ben pour galoche...
-N'importe quoi, toi.
-Ben, en vrai, euh...
Déjà, je vais commencer
par lui glisser quelques mots.
-Tu vas dire "oh, t'es trop belle,
t'as de belles lunettes,
"t'as des beaux cheveux" ?
Quoi, comme mots ?
-Ca... Ben quelques mots,
genre "t'es belle" et tout ça,
des mots basiques, à peu près.
-C'est pas comme ça
que tu vas y arriver.
Déjà, il faut te faire beau gosse.
Ca, c'est important.
L'haleine, surtout. Voilà.
-Ouais, parce que si tu pues
de la gueule, ouh !
Ca va pas aller loin, hein !
-Sinon, faut que tu fasses
que la regarder,
que tu fasses des gestes,
genre en mode tu viens,
tu fais câlin,
des trucs sur la joue,
ou là, par exemple,
ou je sais pas, quelque part.
Tu lui touches les cheveux, surtout.
Si elle te dit "arrête, j'aime pas",
ben t'arrêtes.
Et voilà.
-Et voilà.
-Tu la taquines un peu.
-Houlà, ça part un peu loin, là !
-Ben non, c'est comme ça
qu'il faut faire pour draguer.
-Ah non.
-Ben si.
Toi, tu sais pas.
Moi, je sais.
-Envoie-lui, je sais pas,
des trucs d'amour...
-Des trucs d'amour ?
-Ouais, je sais pas,
"je t'aime, bébé,
"tu me manques trop"...
-Tu dis "tu me manques"...
-Non, je vais pas envoyer ça.
-Tu dis :
"Coucou, bébé, je t'aime trop,
"c'est quand
que tu vas venir me voir ?"
-Ben non, ben non, mais ça...
Mais ça... Mais ça, t'envoies ça
quand t'es en couple, d'accord,
mais pas...
Mais pas avant...
-"Coucou, t'arrives quand ?
Tu me manques".
Et le tour est joué.
-"On se voit quand ?
"On boit un verre,
on mange au resto ?
"On va à la fête foraine ?"
Je sais pas, moi.
Invite-la à dormir,
je sais pas.
Fais un truc, invite-la à l'hôtel...
-Ouais, non, l'hôtel, c'est bizarre.
On va éviter l'hôtel.
-Je sais pas, invite-la
dans ta chambre, je sais pas.
Chez toi, chez ta mère,
chez ton oncle...
Je sais pas, moi !
Fais un truc.
"Coucou, je t'appelle,
tu fais quoi ?"
Ras-le-bol, hein.
Tu la couches pas,
tu veux pas coucher.
-Ben normal que...
-Tu veux pas être en couple ?
-Ben si, mais je vais pas...
-Ben ouais, je sais pas...
-Tu te promènes,
tu dis "je t'aime", tu te colles
un peu à elle, je sais pas.
-C'est pas ça du tout.
-Tu lui fais des bisous
de temps en temps.
-Qu'est-ce que tu me racontes ?
-C'est ça.
-Moi, je fais les eye contacts.
Ca marche toujours.
-Dis-nous, c'est quoi ?
-Tu regardes la personne
dans les yeux.
T'arrêtes pas de la regarder
tout le temps,
tu la regardes dans les yeux
et tout.
-Ouais, en fait...
En fait, en face,
tu attires le regard de la personne
et voilà, quoi ?
C'est ça ?
-Ben non.
-Ben si.
-Ben si !
Tu regardes dans les yeux
et tu fais comme ça.
Il grogne.
-Vous allez trop vite, là.
-Mais non, les eye contacts,
-Tu regardes la personne,
tu ne clignes pas d'un seul oeil.
-Mais c'est pas ça du tout,
un eye contact.
-Alors, c'est quoi ?
-Explique-nous !
-L'intelligente des eye contacts.
-Un eye contact,
c'est quand t'arrêtes pas
de la regarder,
tu la regardes dans les yeux
et lui ou elle, pareil.
-Ben, c'est...
Il rit.
Mais c'est ce qu'on te dit,
en plus !
-Non !
-Mais si !
-Tu la regardes, elle te regarde,
tu le regardes, il te regarde.
Après, tu t'approches,
il s'approche.
Tu t'approches,
-Oh là là...
-T'es vraiment bête.
C'est quoi, la fille de tes rêves ?
-La fille de mes rêves ?
Ben moi, je la vois blonde,
blonde avec les cheveux
un peu caramel,
euh, les cheveux longs...
Non, pas longs,
à moitié longs, plutôt.
-Ben... Moui.
-Ouais... Un peu grande...
-Un peu comme...
-A peu près ma taille, quoi.
Une poitrine moyenne...
-Eh, on s'en fout, des formes.
-Et les fesses ?
-Ben, et les yeux...
un peu bleus...
Enfin, bleu ciel.
-Les fesses ?
-Non.
-Les femmes...
Propos indistincts
-Si t'es pas un mec,
tu peux pas comprendre.
-Voilà.
-Tu peux pas comprendre ce que nous,
les garçons, on ressent.
-Vous, vous comprenez
notre douleur des règles ?
Vous les comprenez pas.
-C'est normal.
-Normal, on les a pas !
Comment veux-tu
qu'on les comprenne ?
-Oh, tu sais faire l'amour ?
Non ?
On t'a jamais appris ?
Il rit.
-Alors ?
-Je sais pas,
tu connais les sites ?
-Tu comptes faire l'amour ?
-Plus tard ?
-Pour avoir des gosses,
il faut bien.
-T'es pas obligée.
-T'es pas vraiment obligée,
parce que tu sais,
y a une autre technique.
Tu peux avoir un médecin
qui met directement le truc
des garçons
directement
dans l'ovule des filles.
-L'ovule, ça veut dire quoi ?
-Tu vas l'apprendre en SVT.
-C'est en cours de SVT, en fait.
Je veux dire, en fait, l'ovule...
-C'est ce qui permet...
-C'est un noyau...
-C'est ce qui va permettre
de faire le bébé,
de faire la forme du bébé.
-Ah...
-Baiser, c'est pour le plaisir,
l'amour, c'est pour les gosses.
-Euh, ben moi, en fait, pour moi,
faire l'amour, c'est, euh...
C'est quoi ?
En vrai, c'est pour le plaisir...
Y a pas de différences...
Ouais, y a pas trop de différences,
en vrai,
même, je crois, pas du tout.
Parce qu'en vrai,
c'est un peu les mêmes choses.
-Baiser, c'est pour le plaisir,
et l'amour, c'est pour faire
des trucs sérieux.
Par exemple, pour baiser,
tu mets la capote.
Faire l'amour, tu la mets pas.
-Après, si la capote,
elle casse, ben tant pis.
-Mais bon, après,
y a pas trop de différences.
-Ouais, y en a pas.
-Si la capote,
elle a un tout petit trou,
c'est fichu.
Caquètement d'oiseau
...
Propos indistincts au loin
Rires au loin
-Tu vas te calmer, ouais ?
Ouais, c'est ça,
arrête de bégayer !
Arrêtez, arrêtez.
Rires et propos indistincts au loin
...
-En plein dans le mille !
-Et toi, ferme ta gueule.
...
Ferme ta gueule.
Vociférations
-Eh !
...
-Reste là.
-Il est même pas dans le quartier !
-T'es un grand malade, toi.
-Oh !
Vociférations
...
Propos indistincts au loin
-J'ai plus envie de parler d'eux.
-Ouais, vas-y...
-Miskine.
-Ouais.
Dès qu'il t'embête,
eh ben, t'arrêtes.
Genre, tu pars, et là,
s'ils t'insultent,
tu leur dis :
"C'est quoi, le problème ?"
-Ils me poussent, après,
ça part en bagarre, wesh !
-Il me pousse, je lui en mets une,
mais là...
-C'est ce que j'ai voulu faire.
-Mais là, vu que j'étais là,
je t'aurais séparé.
S'ils me poussaient,
tu me séparerais.
J'ai bien fait de te séparer.
-Mais alors, ils me poussent,
je dois rien faire ?
-Non, mais moi, tu pousses,
je l'aurais poussé,
mais toi, tu m'aurais séparé.
Lui, il te pousse,
tu le pousses, je te sépare.
-Si tu gagnes, je te sépare pas,
si tu perds, si.
-Ben non.
-Si.
-Si tu veux, tu fais ça, mais...
-Et alors ?
-Je voulais pas de baston.
-Il me pousse, je suis la victime,
je m'allonge, je prie
pour qu'il me frappe pas ?
-On est potes, pourquoi tu te bats ?
-Potes ?
-Avant.
-Ils cherchent la baston
mais on est potes...
-Mais avant.
Avant, on était potes et là...
Les petits,
ils insultaient et tout, là.
-Ah ben eux, c'est des petits,
je vais pas mettre une pêche
aux petits.
-Par contre, le grand, des fois...
Des fois, toi, tu partais
et lui, il venait te chercher.
Des fois, il partait,
tu venais le chercher.
-Ben, normal.
-Ben non. Il a arrêté,
faut que t'arrêtes.
-Vas-y...
Parle même plus de lui.
Il va me rendre fou.
-Oui...
-Qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
parler ?
-On continue ?
-Ben, je...
Quoi te dire d'autre ?
Elle est drôle, euh...
-"Drôle, euh..."
-Elle porte des talons ?
-Elle porte quoi,
comme baskets ?
-Elle a des talons...
-Elle porte de la marque ?
-Non.
-Elle porte pas de la marque ?
-Elle se maquille ?
-Bah oui.
-Est-ce que t'as déjà galoche ?
-Bah oui !
-Et toi ?
-Bah ouais.
-A quel âge, toi ?
-Moi, à quel âge ?
-Ouais.
-Pfiou !
Ca remonte, hein.
-A quel âge ?
-Je sais pas, euh...
A peu près à l'âge...
-5-6 ans ?
-Non, hé, bien plus.
-Moi, c'est 5-6 ans.
-Vers 13 ans.
-Et toi ?
-5-6 ans.
-Non.
-Pourquoi tu mens ?
-J'étais encore en maternelle.
-C'est pas...
C'est pas un bisou comme ça.
Comme ça...
-Ben, c'est ce que je fais
avec mon copain.
-T'as un copain ?
-Oui, j'ai un copain.
-Ah ouais !
Et tu vas pas un peu sur le côté
et tout ça ?
-Tu fais pas :
"Mmh ! Mmh !"
-Ca sert à rien,
on a tous les deux un petit nez.
-Ca veut dire quoi,
une "pute" ?
-Ben pour moi, en fait...
Maintenant, mon goût s'est affiné,
quoi, mais pour moi,
c'est les meufs, en fait,
qui font...
-Qui font leur b...
-Qui font trop la maline,
qui veulent trop faire
leur intéressante,
belle, tout ça...
Qui c'est, en fait...
Euh, qui vont dire...
Euh...
Ben...
Ben, qui s'habillent mal,
tout ça, en fait. Qui s'habillent...
Avec des vêtements
qui leur vont pas, tout ça.
-Avec des vêtements de pute quoi.
-Mais c'est pas ce que tu fais là,
aujourd'hui ?
Il rit.
-Non, mais !
Avant, je détestais.
-T'insinues que ta soeur,
c'est une pute ?
-Non, c'est pas que j'insinue,
c'est juste pour blaguer !
Je dis pas que ma soeur,
c'est une pute.
-On a bien compris ça ?
-Oui.
-Voilà.
-Et c'était pour blaguer, hé...
Pour donner un peu d'humour.
-Han !
-De "l'émour" !
-De "l'humour" !
-Waouh, vous avez pas d'humour,
en fait.
-C'était pas de l'humour.
-Eh ben, pour toi,
c'est quoi, une pute ?
-C'est une pute !
Ils rient.
-Ben, détaille...
-Euh, je sais pas, moi...
"Ils" ont...
"Ils" ont toujours mettre
plein de maquillage,
fond de teint, mascara...
Du rouge à lèvre,
rouge, bleu, jaune...
A-Av-Av-Avec des talons
qui font ça...
-Non, ça existe pas,
des talons qui font ça.
-Des faux ongles, euh...
Après, d'autre...
Pfiou...
-T'es pas...
Mmh ?
-Quoi ?
-Merci d'insinuer !
Le grand frère rit.
-Non, ça, c'est vrai.
(-Han, il m'a traitée de pute !
Je vais le dire à maman !)
-De l'humour.
-Eh, quoi, c'est vrai,
tu mets toujours...
Tu mets toujours des faux ongles
quand tu vas à Action,
tu fais des caprices à maman
pour avoir des faux ongles.
-C'est même pas vrai, déjà,
donc tais-toi.
-Estime pas que t'es une pute.
-Ben lui, ouais.
-Non, il a dit des trucs vulgaires.
Ben moi, j'ai dit comme elle.
Elle, elle est toujours...
elle est toujours vulgaire.
-Ouais, t'es vulgaire,
mais c'est...
-C'est un style vestimentaire.
-Eh ben ça définit pas le...
Ca définit pas le mot de "pute".
-Ah ! Ah, OK.
Soupir
Des klaxons résonnent au loin.
Ah, y a un mariage !
...
-Ah ouais.
-Vive les mariés !
Rire
Klaxons
...
-Tu l'as en sweat, aussi ?
-Ouais, ouais.
Pas mal.
T'as le tee-shirt, aussi.
Y en a pas souvent,
des couleurs comme ça.
Ah là là...
Babillement
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
C'est pas bon !
"Baaah !"
-Tu t'es fait un piercing au nez ?
-Ouais.
Le bébé pousse un cri.
Elle rit.
Babillement
-Ben alors ?
Ben alors ?
Le bébé rit.
Avec son petit rire, là.
T'as toujours pas
de piercing ?
-Si, j'en ai un à la langue.
-Ah ouais, bon.
-C'est Enaya, qu'elle s'appelle ?
-Enaya, ouais.
-Enaya !
Tu me donnes la main ?
Elle rit.
Enaya babille.
Regarde.
-Il est pas mal, celui-là.
-Regarde.
-Mince.
"Oh, c'est qui, ça ?"
"C'est qui ?"
Enaya rit.
Enaya pleure.
...
Ben alors ?
Tu fais plus la moto ?
...
Fais la moto.
-La moto ?
-Fais-le.
...
Oh...
Fais-le.
Fais la moto.
-Regarde le doudou.
Il veut te faire un câlin.
Fais un câlin.
Elles se pâment.
Câlin !
Elles rient.
Oh, elle est belle !
Fais un câlin.
-Elle est fatiguée.
Un jouet fait "pouêt".
Enaya rit.
-Oh ! Ben non, hé !
...
Elle rit.
-Arrête ! Rigole pas.
Enaya pleurniche.
...
Fais-le pas glisser.
-Maman !
Maman !
-Je vais pas te la voler, ta maman !
-Va le chercher.
Enaya babille.
...
-Voilà.
-C'est pas trop compliqué,
avec la petite ?
-Non, pas du tout.
-Tu fais quoi ?
T'as trouvé ton appart ?
-Non, pas encore.
Ils m'ont positionnée sur un,
début novembre.
Sur l'avenue,
au-dessus de la pizzeria.
Donc maintenant, j'attends...
novembre.
-Tu veux rester dans le quartier ?
-Ouais.
-Tu veux d'autres enfants ?
-Ben, pas pour le moment.
Je vais attendre, déjà,
qu'Enaya puisse comprendre,
qu'elle va à l'école...
Qu'elle va à l'école, que...
Ben, qu'elle grandisse un peu,
pour après, lui faire comprendre,
par la suite...
...
-Et à l'hôpital,
c'était comment ?
-Au début, ça a été dur,
avec les douleurs,
mais une fois qu'elle arrive,
t'oublies tout.
Maintenant,
faut penser à elle.
Faut faire avec.
Mmh.
-Mais tu sortais plus.
-Non, ben je voulais beaucoup
me reposer, aussi,
avant son arrivée...
-Tu m'as manqué, quand même.
-Oui, je le sais très bien.
-Enaya ?
...
Tu viens ?
Ouais.
Les oiseaux ?
...
Viens !
Ah !
...
-Oh !
-Les oiseaux ?
-"Hé ayo !"
"Hé ayo !"
-Les oiseaux, ouais.
...
-Et toi, ça va,
depuis le temps ?
-Bah, ouais, bof...
Genre, je suis un peu perdue
et tout.
-Ah bon ?
Pour quoi faire ?
-Je sais pas.
-"Hé ayo !"
"Hé ayo !"
"Ayo !"
-Après, quand t'as pas
la tête à parler,
que tu veux être seule...
Mmh.
Enaya rouspète.
-Mmh ?
-Hon-hon !
Non !
...
C'est pas à manger, ma main.
Enaya babille.
...
-Y a pas si longtemps,
genre, je me suis dit :
je suis pas un petit, maintenant,
je suis un peu un ado donc...
Il est temps de grandir, quoi.
Et puis ben voilà,
je commence à grandir.
C'est que le début.
Je sais que, genre,
je veux être un homme, quoi, que...
Dans ma tête, je suis encore un...
Genre...
Je sais pas comment dire ça,
genre...
Dans ma tête, je suis encore
un gamin de 3 ans.
Plus on est grand,
plus il y aura des bourbiers
dans sa vie qui vont arriver.
Je sais me battre, mais bon,
à quoi ça sert, de se battre ?
Je suis pas un emmerdeur, moi,
en fait.
Moi, j'attends que c'est eux
qui viennent.
Je vais pas les voir :
"Vas-y, viens, on se bat."
Ouais, à un moment, je me faisais
frapper par tout le monde.
Je me faisais victim'
par tout le monde.
J'étais la salope ou la pute
de tout le monde, en fait.
Je me faisais frapper
par tout le monde.
Je connaissais des bonnes personnes,
genre, je comptais sur eux,
si je me faisais frapper.
Ben non.
Ils restaient dans leur coin.
Juste parce que c'était les plus
forts du collège qui me frappaient.
Même si c'était des faibles,
ils venaient même pas.
Ils restaient dans leur coin.
Je leur disais : "Restez bien là
mais venez plus me parler."
J'ai affronté ma mère tout seul.
Je l'ai affrontée tout seul,
ma mère.
Et puis,
y a pas si longtemps,
y a deux mois,
en fait, j'ai compris que,
maintenant, j'ai grandi,
et maintenant, je vais me défendre.
Et puis, depuis ce jour-là,
ils viennent plus me faire chier.
Moi, ma peur, là, en ce moment,
c'est d'être viré de mon collège.
Je travaille bien,
j'ai des bonnes notes
mais c'est mon comportement
qui plaît pas.
J'ai pas envie de dormir à
l'internat, j'ai pas envie
de voir mon petit frère
que trois jours par semaine.
Genre, lui, je le ferai passer
toujours avant nous. Toujours.
Moi, j'ai sept ans de plus que lui
donc maintenant,
c'est à moi de montrer l'exemple.
Vu que je suis ado,
vu que c'est encore un petit gosse,
genre il sait bien parler et tout,
à moi de montrer l'exemple.
Je suis son grand frère,
donc voilà...
On sait pas ce que c'est
que de ressentir les autres,
quand on est petit.
Quand on est grand, on peut savoir
ce qu'ils ressentent, les autres.
Quand on est petit, on sait pas, ça.
Genre, on sait pas ce qu'on veut.
Quand on est grand,
on sait ce qu'on veut.
Faut plus avoir besoin
de ses parents
pour faire
des petites choses,
pour faire ceci, cela,
faut se débrouiller tout seul.
Quand t'es grand,
t'as tout ce que tu veux, quoi,
des gosses et tout,
genre des enfants, une belle maison.
C'est ça, mon rêve, moi,
pas avoir d'emmerdes, etc.
Je pense que c'est ça,
le bonheur, en fait.
-Je recommence ?
-Evite de faire ça !
-Oui mais aussi...
Je veux lancer !
-Enfin, pourquoi ? Là, tu tires
en l'air, tu mets ton doigt.
-Mon doigt ?
J'avais fait comme ça...
1, 2...
Il est encore sur mon doigt.
-Il est derrière.
-Il est où ?
Ah !
-Y a un noeud.
-Attends, j'arrive.
-Oui ?
(-Regarde.)
-C'est pas grave.
-T'as fini ?
-Non, y a un gros noeud.
-Moi, je le fais.
-On va couper...
...et on va refaire.
-Tu me le donnes ?
-Attends, on va le refaire.
Tiens la canne à pêche.
-Oh, Tony !
-Ouais, c'est un poisson.
Tu l'as vu ?
-Dépêche-toi, y a un poisson.
-Il était gros ou petit ?
-Il était gros, je l'ai vu passer.
Il ressemblait à un dauphin.
Comme un...
Comme un bar.
Dépêche-toi !
S'te plaît, dépêche-toi,
il est... Il est...
Il est passé par là,
à peu près.
Du coup, on va le lancer
par là-bas.
(Dépêche-toi.)
-Un gros préservatif !
-Vas-y, éclate-le.
-On va éclater une pierre.
Bris de verre
Je sais pas monter
Putain de sa grand-mère
Voilà ma soeur
Putain de sa grand-mère la pute
Kyliana
Il y a une capote
Un garçon crie.
Tu t'en bas les couilles toi
Je te le dis il sait pas lancer
Sa mère la pute
Kyliana !
Kyliana ?
-1, 2...
-Je t'attrape !
-4, 5, 6...
-50, tu comptes jusqu'à 50.
-10, 11, 12...
-Il triche !
-15, 16, 17...
-Il a triché !
-18, 19, 20, 21,
22, 23, 24, 25, 26
27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33,
34, 35, 36, 37...
39... 50.
Caché ou pas caché, j'arrive !
-Non ! T'as pas le droit !
Tu recomptes !
-Si, il a le droit !
-Non !
-Caché ou pas caché, j'arrive !
-MAIS NON !
-Si !
-Ah non !
-Mais j'étais pas caché !
On n'est pas tous cachés !
-Il est là, Kylian !
C'est une grosse balance !
-Putain, j'avais pas joué !
-Hé ! Vas-y, viens là !
-Non !
-Viens là !
Un chien aboie.
-Et dépêche-toi !
-Non !
-Tu rentres !
-Fais pas ton malin !
-Je fais pas mon malin,
j'ai pas envie.
-Je te dis que tu rentres !
Tu rentres !
Dans 2 secondes, t'es pas là...
-Non, je reste dehors.
-Il faut sortir le chien.
...
Hé, je te parle !
-Je vais le sortir à 21h.
-Non, tu viens là !
-Il est 20h43,
je vais le promener après.
Après !
Dans cinq minutes !
-Hé, t'as 13 ans !
C'est pas toi qui décides
quand est-ce que tu rentres !
On t'a dit tu rentres,
tu rentres !
Tu sais quoi ?
Fais ton malin !
-Après !
C'est bon, là ? Non ?
-Oh, on est là !
-C'est bon,
je le ferai après !
-Tu fais ton malin.
-Barre-toi.
-La racaille du quartier,
tu fais ton malin.
-Barre-toi, Esteban !
-Y a des bouts de verre
en bas de la maison.
-Des bouteilles, y a pas que moi.
Demande à tout le monde.
-Je t'ai vu toi.
-Ouais, et après ?
Demain matin,
c'est de la balance ?
-Je t'ai vu toi.
-Demain matin, c'est de la balance ?
Demain matin, j'ai déjà les flics
sur le dos, c'est ça ?
T'as dit quoi ?
Propos indistincts
Il est malade, lui.
Tonnerre
...
Un chien aboie.
Moteur de mobylette
...
-L'autre jour, je me suis levée
au matin, j'ai pris mes affaires.
Je suis partie
rejoindre des copines.
Ensuite, on a marché
jusqu'à la mer.
On a marché pendant des heures.
On a longé les côtes,
on est arrivées sur une plage,
on a mangé.
Je me suis allongée dans le sable,
j'ai fermé les yeux...
et je me sentais bien,
j'étais loin de tout,
loin du quartier,
loin du lycée,
loin de ma famille.
Genre j'avais envie
de plus repartir,
j'avais envie
de disparaître.
Je crois, j'étais bien là-bas,
je voulais rester.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA